Josette: Hi I'm Joseete Sheeran, the head
of the world food program in Davos.
Many of you may know that we're the world’s
largest humanitarian organization,
and many of you may know that we feed people
all over the world including
three million people in Davos -- in Darfur
every day.
What you may not know is with the cash we
have which is half our budget, we procure
-- spend
eighty percent of it procuring from farmers
in more than 70 developing nations.
And so today, when we fill this cup for school
children in Mozambique, eighty percent
of that food comes from local farmers.
That food would never be seen on global markets
because they don’t have the
transportation and the ability to move it.
So the World Food program goes to
the farms, gets the food and fills the cup.
This is a win-win solution, and we are very
proud of the fact that we spend
almost seven hundred million dollars a year
procuring food from small farmers throughout
the developing
world to help feed people in Darfur, to help
feed schoolchildren all over
the world.
So, help give us support for these local farmers,
and break the cycle of hunger right at its
root.
Thank you.